it just went crazy
and the whole thing was like a split
second thing
and i remember sitting there lying there
thinking i'm not going to die
i'm not dying here
my name is leroy smith and i'm here
today to do an interview with the bbc
about incident what happened over 20
years ago
i'm james seymour i'm a retired police
officer
i'm now a member of police staff
training police drivers
[Music]
i grew up with my grandma my mum got
murdered when i was two
and i left school from about
13 started doing
burglaries robberies and
went to prison got four months came back
out
same thing went again and this cycle
just continued
i grew up in kent uh i came from a very
religious background
where literally the ten commands were
taken as they were
had no telly no radio by the time i got
to
late teens i decided i wanted to to move
out and do something
so it was either the armed forces or the
police
in the 90s brixton was at was and still
is
a is a dangerous place the whole
community is
violent and society is violent in
general but i was just
at the time more violent than everybody
else because i realized that that's the
way
that you get things done there's a lot
of deep feelings
especially at brixton from the 1981
riots
that were still running very deep you
could literally feel the tension
that any slightest thing and this could
could go quite nasty
i know that i wanted myself my colleague
wanted to look for some overtime
and the easiest way to do that would be
a simple drugs arrest
we did a textbook stop back-to-back
separated them
and i said i ain't got nothing to hide
or something along them lens and i had
things
to hide he dropped something on the
floor that i thought was
um crack cocaine so i went to push him
against the wall so i could
um take all the evidence it just went
crazy and the whole thing was like a
split second thing
so it wasn't like
i planned it it just happened
he pulled a handgun from his waistband
hit my colleague in the leg and it's one
of those things where
everything's in slow motion this isn't
really happening this is just a
nightmare i'm going to wake up in a
minute you know the alarm's going to go
off
but it is reality and it was just a
surge of adrenaline
when you live like that you're not
thinking about
other people you think about yourself
it's a self-centered world that you're
living in
the gunman then um fired a third shot
which hit me about a centimeter from the
spine
went across the top in the kidney and
then ripped out the side of my
flesh outside of my body and i remember
sitting there
lying there thinking i'm not going to
die i'm not dying here
the two officers pc simon carroll and pc
jim
seymour are in hospital they stopped to
question two men who were on a motorbike
and both officers were fired at by the
pillion passenger
the new simon was quite bad
for the way he screamed so i'll try to
get to him
but the pain was was too bad i just
couldn't move
[Music]
that is a long time
and i just thought to myself i'm never
getting out
that's what i thought i thought i'm
never getting out
[Music]
i read it some of it i didn't agree with
some of it i found really interesting
and i thought
if he is actually wants to make a
difference to people's lives
i will support him and let him know that
i agree with what you're doing and i
hope you have changed because i always
wanted that
this just feels weird you haven't been
come back until then
i always try to avoid bricks and if i
can have you
be honest i've been back a couple of
times but it seems a bit strange being
here with you
yeah i didn't realize i would feel so so
heavy on my heart
that's the truth now that i'm here
i'm kind of lost for words for that's
not normally like me
i'm pleased leave always doing it with
me you know this is a moment
another moment in my life i won't ever
forget
if it was me i wouldn't forgive someone
so
if it was a situation now where
something
was happening i would put my life
in harm's way for him if i had to
without
hesitation because of everything what's
happened
that's the truth i accept some of my
colleagues are not going to support what
i'm doing
because um i don't know they might be
old school and think well he shot two
police officers
he said they should throw the key away
but for me that's just very
narrow-minded
just for giving leroy has has been
amazing
it's made him feel good it's made me
feel good you know when i was suffering
ptsd um it wasn't just because of the
shooting it was due to a number of
horrific incidents that i'd dealt with
but now without doubt it's one of the
best things i've done in my life
i shot the man point blank
a policeman i don't know him from
nowhere
our parts have collided i'm a gunman
i'm a bad man he's a lawman and now
i can class him as
a friend
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video